welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness ended with our boy steven
seeing things in a whole new light after
his dip in the dark hole but that's
mostly because of the giant pimple on
his forehead oh wait did i say pimple i
meant pupil like what the hell was that
about anyway like one second he's
walking down the street with a whole new
lease on life and then wham the mother
of all eye grains hits and wouldn't you
know it steven left with his excedrin at
home but what is this eye anyway and why
was the good doctor suddenly cool with
his new eyeball buddy by the time
charles calls him to char leave his
reality for a bit well let's speculate
on this my speculation nation nerd
babies but before i continue make sure
to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you
can find our newest doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness shirt that is
not going to last forever so make sure
to pick that up while you can and when
you do you also have the option to leave
a message for inside marvel where me and
eric will read it and you know just
respond back to you it's really fun all
right so remember when sorcerer supreme
wong being the wholesome king that he is
asks his intern strange if he felt okay
after using the darkhold to blue skadoo
into the corpse of his very dead variant
and stephen said yes well uh he was
wrong dead wrong but you know not as
dead as his variant because uh he's no
longer with us i believe that this
eyeball has grown itself on doctor
strange as a direct result of his
tampering with the dark chaos magic of
the darkhold while he was using that
book of badness to dreamwalk through the
multiverse of madness and it will be
through this one eye on his body that
will serve as a vital tool for his
upcoming shenanigans in the dark
dimension alongside his future badass
boo thing with the big ass blade and i
also believe that a huge hint for this
actually comes during the movie's first
surprising eyeball moment with the
arrival of gargantos to the busy streets
of new york because when doctor strange
first arrived at the scene he couldn't
see just what the big idea was and
neither could any of the people around
him like exactly what was picking up
this public transit for this powerful
puerto rican anyway well i think that
pretty much right after doctor strange
notices that he's dealing with a
creature that cannot be seen with
eyeballs from our universe of light he
immediately recognizes that he's dealing
with a dark creature not native to his
universe of light at all much like
another creature that we've seen in the
mcu very recently arthur harrow's street
and bathroom jackals that could not be
seen by anyone but the moon knight who
as hero puts it had a little chaos in
him so what does steven strange do in
this scenario check it out
wait time out did you catch that rewind
that back and play it slow because i do
declare that there is red chaos magic
coming out of stephen's eye of agamotto
an item in the marvel comics that has
historically allowed doctor strange to
see the hidden truths of his reality
allowing him to pierce past the
illusions that laid before him and could
even detect scrolls for a time before
the skrulls updated their biology and
technology to resist the eyes all seeing
gays and sometimes when doctor strange
would use his eye on the comics a third
eye would manifest itself on his
forehead much like we see in the
post-credits scene doctor strange uses
his eye of agamotto relic which used to
be the storage place for the dangerous
infinity stone energies of the time
stone to store and summon dangerous
chaos magic to use when he needs it
because if there's one thing that
multiverse of man has proved is that
doctor strange's spell game has
increased tenfold since we met him in
the first film because remember when he
whipped out like green fire at one point
he could not do that before so it
definitely feels like to me mcu doctor
strange being the studious curious
george of a man that he is studied so
many types of new magic to add to his
arsenal and knowing that his line of
work was likely going to bring him in
contact with dark creatures like
gargantos and the moon knight jackal
that cannot be seen by the naked eye
strange stored some of that dangerous
chaos energy within the eye that he
didn't want swirling around within his
actual physical body only to be used
during emergencies hey our buddies at
helix mattresses have a sister company
all form that makes awesome customized
furniture and thanks to all forms for
sponsoring this video by the way we're
all spending a lot more time at home and
no matter how you're spending that time
your sofa and your chairs are an
integral part of your home that's where
you watch disney plus or eat while
watching disney plus or fall asleep
while watching disney plus or improve
your marriage while watching disney plus
all form lets you personalize your sofa
from over 500 unique combinations of
sizes styles and fabrics they make it
easy to find the perfect furniture for
your space your way new rockstar's
editor john got a brown leather armchair
and ottoman from all form and absolutely
loves them that's a nice chair he dreams
about editing the break room while
getting in a quick nap in his comfy
chair and setup is easy with completely
tool-free assembly because all form
ships direct to consumer they're able to
use really premium materials at a
reasonable price and the best part about
all this is that all form delivers your
couch right to your door for free they
have a 100-day trial so you get more
than three months to make sure that you
love it and if you don't they'll pick it
up for you and you'll get a full refund
we love the all form furniture that
we've gotten and we think that you will
too to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
new rockstars all form is offering 20
off all orders for our audience at
allform.com
new rockstars but hey speaking of that
clia post-credit scene that whole moment
was very heavily inspired by jason
aaron's doctor strange number one from
2015 which finds a doctor strange
walking down the street with his third
eye out and cloak of levitation keeping
his cold ass neck warm as a scarf and as
he does his third eye allows doctor
strange to perceive all the threats
invisible to the natural human eye that
secretly live amongst the populists
around him and i love the scene for the
comics so much because it really shows
how casual doctor strange has become
with this really freaky way of viewing
the universe like constantly being aware
of all these invisible monsters that
slither by unnoticed and sometimes feed
off of humanity without anyone being the
wiser and this is what i believe is
implied by this post-credits scene and
the very power of chaos magic of the
darkhold now afforded steven the gift of
sight without the need of the chaos
magic that he used to store within the
eye of agamotto like messing with the
darkhold quite literally gave doctor
strange chaos vision which strange then
flexes to clea when he sees that she's
about to bring him to dormammu's dark
dimension basically telling her that
he's ready to see whatever he has to
show her in this new dangerous universe
that he barely knows anything about and
this new power could actually end up
being one that stays with strange for
the long run because as the next phase
of the mcu ramps up and more dark
elements start to be introduced this
ability to fight these invisible dark
monsters might just be exclusive to
those people who could actually see them
like doctor strange and moon knight
which might just mean that the mcu might
just need a team of heroes that can
shine this special dark light of red
chaos on these dark creatures because if
earth's golden orange sun isn't enough
the mcu is going to need the red
midnight sun of chaos magic to expose
all these monsters as they try to stalk
in shadow and moon knight and the
multiverse of madness post-credits scene
might just be marvel studios first steps
in establishing the necessity of a
midnight sun's team and having the
midnight suns be called the midnight
suns as opposed to the gender-specific
suns s-o-n-s allows for dope members
like the monster hunting elsa bloodstone
to be on the team as well because they
are for sure going to need the magic of
her blood gym if [ __ ] like
harrow intend to continue letting the
dogs out like some type of black magic
baja men but that is what i believe this
i means for the future of the mcu in
doctor strange three but what do you
guys think let us know in the comment
section below but anyways thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some really
weird [ __ ] and insane theories but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media make
sure you hit that notification bell on
youtube so you can get notifications
every time we upload a video and again
do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to pick up our latest
obsession shirt inspired by multiverse
of madness because it's super dope and
stock to last forever so hit up new
rockstars merch today but again thank
you guys so much for watching this video
i love you guys so much and i'll see you
guys later goodbye
[Music]
you